est une céréale qui pourrait facilement
transformer vos petits déjeuners
on connaît le bol de grue au chaud mais
sur les réseaux sociaux ce sont les
recettes de grues au froid qui se
multiplient
en anglais on l'appelle oven night out
soit le gruau de la veille ou encore le
gruau
le gruau froid va avoir une texture un
peu plus pudding versus le gruau chaud
donc il y a c'est ça il y a cette
texture là qui va être vraiment
différente c'est une autre sensation en
bouche je pense que le gruau frigo vient
répondre aussi à un besoin d'avoir un
produit qui est différent du gruau cuit
qui est un peu plus visqueux
c'est dans sa cuisine que Christelle
styliste culinaire a développé ses
recettes de gruau de la veille des grues
au sans cuisson qui font maintenant
partie de son livre de recettes les
flabugs gruau ça c'est le classique que
j'avais parce que c'est celui que mon
fils adore manger mais aux fruits rouges
aux fruits congelés c'est avoine les
yogourt vanille moi avec les gruaux
pourquoi j'aime manger en fait c'est que
j'ai pas faim après contrairement des
fois avec les tartines ou quoi j'ai plus
un petit creux vers 11 heures là ça me
soutient suffisamment
Lavoine c'est un grand entier qui va
contenir plus de protéines que les
autres grains donc il y a un effet qui
est au niveau de la satiété qui va être
meilleur que d'autres céréales et la
voix elle est très riche en fibres
particulièrement une fibre soluble
unique qu'on appelle la bêta glucane
donc les films de Lavoine sont
intéressantes pour le microbiote alors
nos petites bactéries dans notre système
digestif moi ce que j'aime c'est
rajouter du yogour pour le côté crémeux
puis l'acidité en plus aussi des graines
de chia si on a ou des graines de lin
elle produisent un effet en fait un peu
plus ferme je pense que ce qui plaît aux
gens c'est le fait que ça soit rapide
nutritif on a des journées qui va vite
dans la routine du matin ça s'intègre
vraiment très bien
et pour aller toujours plus vite
l'industrie nous propose maintenant des
versions déjà mélangées il suffit
d'ajouter le liquide froid de son choix
brassé et de le déposer au frigo que je
trouve intéressant dans cette produit
c'est que c'est de Lavoine canadienne
nous avons demandé à Amélie Charest
nutritionniste d'analyser l'offre de
produits offert un épicerie que tous les
produits que j'ai analysés le premier
ingrédient aide la voix donc ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle ce qui a attiré mon
attention c'est que la plupart des
produits sont très faibles en sodium
chaque compagnie propose sa recette et
selon les mélanges différentes formes
d'avoine sont utilisées avec des ajouts
de graines de chia de noix de fruits
séchés et de sucre attendez un autre
élément à surveiller d'abord il y a les
catégories de produits qui vont avoir
des fruits séchés ce qui est une très
belle alternative un produit qui est
souvent plus complet puis on va avoir
aussi certains produits qui contiendra
pas de fruits séchés mais qu'on va avoir
ajouté du sucre une deux voire même
trois cuillères à thé de sucre et là on
a un produit qui est franchement
peut-être un peu trop sucré mais le
gruau frigo peut avoir toutes les
composantes d'un déjeuner complet selon
le guide alimentaire canadien soit un
gré entier des fruits des protéines et
parfois beaucoup de protéines ce produit
ici on a des la protéine de pois qui est
ajoutée et ça va augmenter de façon
importante la valeur nutritive la teneur
en protéines est 4 fois plus élevée que
d'autres produits qui ont pas de graines
de chia et de protéines végétales de
poids d'ajouter
qui soit fait maison ou du commerce la
durée au frigo sera en fonction de tous
les ingrédients et du ratio de liquide
alors ici on a de l'avoine Lavoine
rapide donc
qu'elle mérite d'être de produire un
résultat un peu plus
crémeux dans le fond Lavoine classique
donc les gros flocons d'avoine qui vont
avoir un petit peu plus de tenue mais
pareil qui vont très bien fondre dans le
lait et le Yogo alors je pourrais donc
vous faire le gruau froid au chocolat là
j'ajoute une demi-tasse de flocons c'est
vraiment la fibre qui va réagir avec le
liquide donc si on fait cuire on
accélère ce processus là puis si on fait
pas cuire mais c'est le temps qui vient
compenser qui vient aider on peut le
voir même dans le pot c'est très liquide
mais Lavoine et le chien vont absorber
le liquide et donc ça va créer une
texture plus ferme le lendemain donc il
y a plus qu'à le mettre au frigo toute
la nuit ou au minimum catastrophe
de la capacité à se gonfler dans l'eau
et à un gel visqueux dans l'estomac et
l'intestin ce qui va avoir la
particularité de retenir les molécules
de cholestérol retenir un peu les
molécules de sucre et donc d'avoir un
effet modeste mais quand même
intéressant sur notre cholestérol
sanguin et notre taux de glycémie le
taux de sucre sanguin moi j'aime ça une
cuillère à soupe de souvent de sucre en
liquide pour que ça se mélange bien et
des épices si on a le goût de la
cannelle de la vanille ça va permettre
de moins sucré généralement ça apporte
le côté sucré sans ajouter de sucre
alors en attendant souvent à sucrer
davantage que ce qu'on pense qu'on sucre
soit notre cuillerée à thé de sucre va
être même un peu plus élevé donc on est
probablement mieux mesuré
le prix des produits en épicerie varie
d'environ 1 dollar à plus de 5 dollars
la portion c'est sûr que c'est simple de
faire un gruau de la veille maison c'est
beaucoup moins cher aussi on parle
d'environ c'est facile de s'en sortir à
moins d'un dollars par portion alors que
les produits qui nous sont offerts sont
beaucoup plus dispendieux plus que le
dôme le triple le cadre c'est beaucoup
plus cher la beauté du gruau quand même
c'est que on peut le personnaliser assez
facilement je voulais être ni comme ça
comme si c'était un gris au chaud
réconfortant est-ce que c'est tout aussi
réconfortant moi je trouve que c'est
tout aussi réconfortant c'est sûr que ça
apporte aussi de la fraîcheur et je
trouve ça le fun à manger le matin